United States three four one one was
scheduled to leave Chicago O'Hare
Airport at 5:40 p.m. on Sunday April 9th
to Louisville Kentucky
but after dragging a passenger off the
flight and a two-hour delay it turned
into one of the biggest PR disasters an
airline has ever seen of course the
impetus of this entire news story is
that airlines sell more seats than they
have it's just better business with any
flight a certain number of people won't
show up
that's called a no-show ring flying with
an empty seat is a lost opportunity for
an airline to make money even if someone
did buy a ticket for that seat so many
airlines have instilled complicated
systems to predict how many people will
miss their flight that no-show rate
varies hugely by route and date in
United's Network Chicago where flight
three four-one one left from likely has
a high no-show rate since it's their hub
a large percentage of the passengers
taking a flight from Chicago connects
from another flight and since
one-quarter of US domestic flights
arrive late many people miss their
connections in addition there are a ton
of competing airlines and modes of
transport from Chicago so it's not a
huge deal for passengers to change their
plans to leave a few hours or days later
on a flight from say Bangor Maine a
small rural Airport to Washington DC
passengers are much less likely to miss
or decide not to show up for their
flight no passengers are connecting
through Bangor on to this flight to DC
and there are also very few alternatives
with only 10 to 15 flights a day and no
train service missing a flight out of
Bangor is much more inconvenient than
one out of Chicago flights on Sunday
nights like flight 3 4 1 1 are also
likely to have a lower no-show rate
since travelers are weary to get back to
work on Monday there's no good public
data on how many passengers miss their
flights it's a closely guarded secret
but this data is used by airlines to
build models that predict how many seats
airlines can safely oversell the good
news is that these models are getting
better in 1990 US airlines denied
boarding to about 16 out of every 10,000
passengers while today it's down to nine
out of every 10,000
Ginger's with better and better data and
smarter and smarter programs these
models are constantly improving to let
Airlines
sell these non-existent seats more
safely in the end what airlines pay to
compensate those half a million yearly
passengers who are bumped from their
flight is far less than the hundreds of
millions of dollars they can make over
booking until of course it turns into a
worldwide PR disaster so how can you be
sure that you won't be bumped when
airlines do have to involuntarily select
individuals to offload they'll often use
a hierarchical system choosing the
individuals that supposedly have the
least merit to be on the flight or least
value to the airlines on paper
normally a computer will pick those who
checked in last or have no for low
frequent flyer status so if you check in
early even online select a seat and get
your boarding pass you're much more
likely to fly on your flight in addition
having a frequent flyer account even if
you don't use it much will improve your
odds over the majority of people who
don't have one at all you can also fly
airlines that overlook less JetBlue had
to involuntarily deny boarding to only
18 out of 21 million passengers in 2013
since they sell mostly inflexible
tickets with fewer connections
passengers are much more likely to show
up for their flight so JetBlue has a
blanket policy not to over booked
flights well you have to remember with
Airlines however is that they're
constantly trying to find ways to make
more money per seat so that they can
reduce ticket prices that's not to say
that they're altruistic organizations
they just recognize that the number one
determinant to whether someone will fly
their airline is that one number the
ticket price
so they'll take almost any opportunity
to reduce it in order to gain a
competitive advantage
time and time again it's been proven
that the majority of consumers want
cheaper flights more than they want a
better travel experience that's why
budget airlines are making such a
disruption so this whole trend of
unbundled air fares fees for everything
and even over booking is all in response
to what the consumer as one entity wants
cheap flights I hope you enjoyed this
short
and extra Wendover productions video if
you'd like to support the channel you
can do so over at patreon.com slash
Wendover productions I'd also encourage
you to subscribe to catch all my future
videos right when they come out and
follow me on Twitter at Wendover pro to
get updates along the way lastly if you
enjoyed this video you'd probably enjoy
the one on the economics of airline
class which you can find here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in two weeks
for the next full length Wendover
productions video